here we go Game one let's try Knight f3
all right let's let's try something a
little bit more calm I was gonna run
with uh with what I was going to just go
with the Kings Indian attack but I don't
know how I don't know if I'm really a
fan of it if there's already upon a d5
take so I guess a little bit more work
to get that in um okay all right so I'm
gonna pin for right now and I'll either
consider breaking the pin or just
pinning this night you might want to
consider pinning this night hmm I'm used
to seeing ecigs and Bishop 2d6 right
away I don't think it really matters
let's see h3c for Bishop e2 Bishop b5 or
my for candidate moves here just kind of
rough rough thoughts I don't think this
is a pin that I have to be too concerned
about right now so who cares not going
to go with that one thing actually now
with my pawn on c4 if I play Bishop e2
the bishop can take my night and if I
recapture then there's pawn takes but
i'm okay i could probably just get it
back but something to be aware of my
bishop is kind of in some sense
overloaded as soon as i develop it to e2
for as long as this tension remains
between the C&D ponds I'm not afraid
that just yet because it's still in its
home square Bishop takes I just take
with my queen and then there's a clear
view still of that c4 square now if
Bishop d 6 which is what I'm
anticipating i'm just going to back up
and if takes captured towards the center
so have a good reason not to I don't
know if there's a big advantage in
maintaining this tension I don't know if
I would really ok this is this is a
possibility but I don't know how
realistic it is to place see five and
release the pressure on d5 playing c5
eventually black will be trying to get
an e5 does black have enough to get it
to get this in right now maybe I should
um finally just capture here and then
play Bishop e2 breaking the pin go with
that I'm going to look to try and maybe
put pressure on this c7 pun this is a
half-open see file soon enough my rook
will play here and apparently black is
considering night takes or Bishop takes
Bishop at this point take with the night
then there's a two-to-one majority in
the center I don't know if that's really
something i could put to good use okay
and I don't know that I'm really afraid
of Knight takes Knight that's just going
to reinforce my son I think now's the
time since my opponent is the side that
already has the King castled I better
get castled soon so now i'm at least one
step away brigade is c1 castle those are
ensuing moves i might as well pre move
that one i have a slight edge on the
clock which is rare and one reason to
maybe not okay now this is a spot I was
going to go to anyhow let me try to
finish that thought one um what was I
going to say oh if Bishop d3 and Knight
takes pawn takes this e five move has
maybe the potential to land a fork if my
bishop is on d3 so this a five advance I
don't have to worry about it getting to
e4 with the fork if my vision was on d3
I would it's just castle so a single
move away from being fully developed
just to say just moving my queen so that
my rooks direct connection with one
another so what is going to be happening
with this night no unpinned bishop here
if the bishop was on f5 my rook I think
ends up getting trapped beware of that
those bishops can really cover all these
squares from the rope
I've had that happen before okay my rook
um did his job it was just a temporary
watch over C 3 and now it's time to
reposition I'll often get the comment I
don't know what to do like out of the
opening like as far as plans well that
move was a bit it's not really an
in-depth plan but it's just kind of like
a repositioning thing so that's what you
will often find out of the gates out of
the opening your pieces become out of
position so it's not a sophisticated
plan is just being able to answer how
can I improve the position of one of my
pieces ok so what to do I don't want to
do this because Bishop takes and I want
to capture it would open the F file but
I don't want to weaken III okay this
seems good get Mike we know she has some
potential lateral movements in fact I
should have maybe gun with this a little
bit sooner okay I should have been in
pretty moved with this I have the bishop
pair right now okay but these guys are
going to come off and still if the dark
square Bishop scum off I'm well situated
such that my pawns are on dark squares
and my remaining bishop is around on the
light squares so I have a good coverage
in the center and now my queen is maybe
tactically vulnerable like if there's a
capture on this square and then the
queen is protected it seems like I could
just smash smash things open here maybe
I want to put a question this bishop I
don't know maybe I want to just actually
go with something like doubling on the B
file I think that that could be um I
think that could be pretty good yeah I'm
going to go with them that less than two
minutes we're both under two minutes and
whoa wait wait wait a second now I could
just grab this pun I was a slip
and i believe the position is going to
be crumbling very soon now I think the
night well yeah this is this is very
very difficult very difficult okay so
now my queen is hit Knight takes bishop
probably okay and I could take this
Bishop and then win this pond but to be
honest I don't think there's any rush
whatsoever I could I could um I think
one of these will end up falling by
force I really just don't want to allow
either of the either one of these drugs
to get any activity so assuming nothing
serious is being thrown my way no
forceful moves by black and just going
to improve my king position again I
could have taken this [ __ ] up but I'm
not too concerned about it I could maybe
I want to do it now actually you notice
my train of thought change quickly as
soon as i saw this F pawn push because
I'm seeing now that the seventh-ranked
is a bit more exposed and now the bishop
takes rook takes rook takes pawn not
only my netting another pond but I may
have very well wanted to just go here
even if there wasn't a pond there just
like a double two pigs there's not
really going to be a defense you can't
even you can't challenge it I guess
throw the King in the corner and throat
rook on GA but that's very very passive
and now these ponds are going to be
gobbled up there's only one other file
that can maybe be opened but these rooks
have just no play they're just only able
to function how along ranks ok so I'm
going to play here because I want to
take with the check and then the King
has to play here and what's the cleanest
approach actually there's well take
another pot I'm on this
I think I think I'm actually I would
have liked to just come over here I
don't want really any of the rooks to
get active but I think we're going to
have more of a time issue than anything
okay these are just dropping now and I
could just go after all of them really
this is the last guy get rid of him and
there's just nothing nothing doing
just go to squares that are protected
King is cut off just March all right no
time resignation okay good game Shadow
King let's go back back flip the board
and let's see my first thought is really
already at this point with the night
night c96 move to obstruct the sea pond
in Queen pond openings I always tend to
question that unless you go in for a
gambit such as the white side the white
side that might play the black Redeemer
where you have Knight c3 and then you do
efore with f3 but not the case here
there's not really a gambit for black
that I'm seeing although maybe there's
something with like f6 and really trying
to get an e5 because that that is like
the only pawn break really with without
your sepan to maybe challenge my deep on
with you know c5 then it's 'if I've is
the only other palm break that white
really has to be aware of so I just
don't know I mean it's not losing or
anything but I don't know anyhow those
are my thoughts like I see this as a
potential target it didn't turn out to
be the case in the game but just became
very very difficult to deal with the
pressure that I had on the queenside so
what might be better than what am I
getting at here I guess probably just
throw out the King night see what I do
next and then maybe you could get your
bishop out just retain his options even
sometimes he might want to play to d7 or
maybe you want to play for C 596 those
go hand in hand just like you would see
just um with fee and kettling your
bishop you push up your pawn and then
you put the bishop or you push up a pond
you put the bishop in this place
similarly you might want to go with C 5
and then throw the knight on c6 the idea
to put pressure on d4 but now there's a
problem
maybe the other one is just to recapture
at the pond but even so my queen coming
out to be 3 this is this is difficult
this palm being backward another I mean
another thing you might want to just
have your pond up to c6 to reinforce
your Center if you capture with your
pond and you can get a pawn to c6 so
everything is really as you can probably
tell I'm just kind of fixated on this
idea of not obstructing that seafoam and
this is I don't I didn't really don't
know that I gave you a many options here
there's a lot of pressure that I'm
placing on you I do well to just keep
this tension right here if you capture
me I'm happy to recapture I just see it
in my eyes I'm just seeing it more
long-term not as a weakness just you
know double pawns not necessarily
weakness at all more of just long-term
flight square but we're beyond the point
of recovery really you even if you
didn't drop the pond I think it's very
very difficult and I guess I'm just not
so sure about giving up the bishop pair
but I think it's still quite difficult
because of the because of what just I
have a very clear plan at this point I'm
just doubling on the B file and just
kind of on the defensive and there's
it's very very easy to go wrong ok good
game shadows king